[Music]
and you're doing it wrong news
somebody might whoop there it is I can't
apologize for a new dish on its menu
after a cultural appropriation okay what
is it is there any other kind of
backlash these days
yeah well for everything alright not
just the appropriation but like races oh
yeah for sure
that's it there's the dish and so those
Swedish meatballs aren't really Swedish
mmm the horse meat was even horsey yeah
but IKEA decided to come out with jerk
chicken and rice and peas the chicken
wasn't actually a Turk so the thing is
this is a Caribbean dish mm-hmm
and they're white people but they use
the wrong ingredients because in the
Caribbean they call beans peas but IKEA
literally used whitewash El Pollo Loco
yeah you're serving this in the UK this
tweet is what sparked the whole thing
this is like he is jerk chicken does
that mean that they ordered it cuz it's
on the play no so they ordered it take a
photo of it and just to take a picture
so [ __ ] like bro the caption says this
is a Kia's jerk chicken and rice and
peas and no I'm not eating it like what
you just put on a plate you Bieber it
and you wasted food pretty much I mean
I'd only get offended if it tastes bad
eat the chicken part who gives a [ __ ] so
the thing is they're saying that like I
said it's usually plated with actual
beans a kidney beans and they're just
like are you [ __ ] serious a quick
google search could have told you the
actual ingredients there onion I'm their
defense around like I could have
researched it is like whoever was
building this could have been like oh is
this actually what I'm making or they
want to splash a green in the right not
literally like jerk chicken white rice
do you know how many things are called
jambalaya
and how many wait different ways is made
yeah it's like [ __ ] nuts dude I'm
like damn is there any consistent
jambalaya recipe out there it's all like
some of its andouille sausage some of
its like [ __ ] chicken some of its
like right just sausage but what if but
what if it's like you're expecting beans
and that comes on your life what the
[ __ ] you baited and switched me your
[ __ ] I feel I feel like I've been had
cuz that I kill you could see it you got
a picture it's like it's in a cafeteria
style ministry yeah you could scoop it
out well cuz if someone told me I'm
getting [ __ ] fries and a burger and
what comes out is potato chips Oh what
the [ __ ]
and they're like that's also a UK thing
I'd be very I'd be very pissed a little
bit pissed I would have been like we eat
it with french fries here in America
dude how much cooler breeze that's
what's so funny bout of [ __ ] like you're
gonna go get a burger today you can get
one with the egg on it and get one with
[ __ ] cotija cheese goat cheese chica
no I'm appropriating it I'm taking it
for mine see nobody else I'm saying you
can [ __ ] you can [ __ ] with it anyway
and nobody cares yeah but you [ __ ] what
you're just making a mistake like this
and this is Jamaican dish and it's the
swedish company making it you're what a
mouth babe you're why I know I'm why I
can't even talk about this no but I sure
do don't here I go yeah there were just
people really upset about it on Twitter
really upset for culture appropriation
but just don't buy the [ __ ] chicken
then does this happen in real life do
people need to shout oh culture
appropriation of people in real life or
does it only happen on to it now you get
you're gonna be in the red coffee shop
listen over here some only white people
on Twitter that are pissed
how many people with dreadlocks that are
actually mad about oh don't say that
because I'll they'll find you I'll let
you know no there are Jamaicans that are
pretty like what the [ __ ] why my buddies
is from Jamaica Jamaica and he would
laugh at this [ __ ] Chinese Jamaicans to
see their friends in France a lot of
Chinese Jamaicans yeah so IKEA said he
was a bob is a Swedish home furnishing
company with a much loved food offer we
take inspiration for many countries
around the
and have always worked to combine
different flavors and ingredients to
offer delicious healthy and affordable
dishes we're aware that our new jerk
chicken served with rice and peas has
created some conversation and in some
cases offense our intention was to
create a dish for people for many people
to enjoy but we appreciate that we may
have got it wrong if you're offended
because something has peas in it yeah
you just have good taste what is what
kind of cuisine is title that well they
just south of the border big us can we
argue the same [ __ ] there but like no
one's talking about this if talking
about put peas in a taco I'd be [ __ ]
pissed but I'd be there in person pissed
yes a man not on Twitter to fight those
poor waiter soup
nah I like your peas with I don't like
peas you've never had a meat pie with
gravy and peas and mashed potatoes I
have have you had a shepherd's pie with
peas it's white and you don't amazing
peas of the worst part every time I want
to eat around hey sweet though series
I'm like peas it burst of sweetness it's
like a mashed something that's well know
it depends the weights so you don't love
them now yeah I love them peas man
they're I'll take us out to go Cyclopes
you don't drown them like you love pizza
yeah shut the [ __ ] you don't drown it in
a Jacuzzi of gravy and eat it like that
no by itself baby because I love it see
that's weird
fish and chips you're calling me weird
radish boy no I took it from your
Mexican culture we mix another food she
isn't like tequila dude I hate you so
you're not real Mexican no I really am
because that was the first she was born
in Mexico that's true [ __ ] up on when
I was like 13 so did I well way to bring
up way to bring up traumatic experiences
for Tim yeah Joe trigger you [ __ ] I
puked on tequila too you know maybe now
Jose will a tentative yeah you're not
drinking
no but he's not drinking it either yeah
you're not drink some don't offend
people in real life only do it on
Twitter by because it's more fun on
Twitter does that mean I can't drink
tequila cuz I'm Japanese and I could
only drink
I mean ditching then I could only drink
Asahi beer yes please
so every culture is only allowed to
[ __ ] eat and drink and create the
food that there is Christmas is better
never touch an avocado yep I love
avocado white people have taken avocado
as our sorry that's appropriation no
publicado toast is ours
I've not got you eating it either it's
imported from my country uh is it really
the roma california no you can't oh you
know you can't expensive cost more than
a dollar each
I agreed house he's a Chinese guy that's
true Chinese American grown avocado
he doesn't just replant it in your house
yep anyway we're talking about are we
talking about so that's the new rule you
gotta be that race to make that food or
else it's only win Chinese people might
go to read about Korea
I love Korean food but we can't eat it
award Okies Park Korean but Koreans only
true according to the 24 and me think
what is 20 for me how did you get that
wrong that beatdown city drives its
rhyme together soon so you remember it
24 more you're fine the round number we
get everything what about it oh yeah so
then like be according to how many
countries are lit up and colored that's
how many countries you kitty hmm oh so
the more makes oh you're super fun I am
have you ever seen paia I love paella
paella they make it different every
[ __ ] where to what's my goal is chill
really make jerk chicken seafood pasta
pork rice yeah like jambalaya
porks do you think that everyone's
grandma makes pea
same know I'm mom does even know what is
but that's what I'm saying dude everyone
does a little my mom's authentic
Japanese food tastes like [ __ ]
really so she can't be an authority and
nothing what can she cook well wait so
you still expecting your mama cook for
you fried fish eggs fried fish pretty
good okay yeah frying is easy yes deep
fries the [ __ ] out of a fish my mom's
good at buying pies from Polly's pies oh
[ __ ] there you go that's pretty American
you can't buy that anymore gonna offend
Paulie Enterprise or what if we were
restricted to only the food that our
parents have like consumed Oh God
thought you'd be all-american dude have
you seen all these memes where dad's are
trying to raise their kids playing the
same Nintendo games they played growing
up oh god no I have not so boring what
the [ __ ] kid play the new game you
weirdos do like it's like you see some
post on Reddit and it's like the kid
playing with an old Nintendo controller
and he's in front of a computer screen
it's like raisin right and I'm like bro
if you're raising them right you'll let
them play the game that all the other
kids are playing right now they go to
school and it's like what gave me
playing I'm like I played Nintendo for a
[ __ ] $19.99 cool like you got kids
already getting his ass beat yeah yeah
well like reason right it's with the
video game it's like reason right is
talk to them spend time with them go
outside and play [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna
play the new cool [ __ ] yeah
God people are late we are that's how
you
well yeah you're putting it with Halo no
we're playing Halo [ __ ] though I also
got a crash bandicoot all three mm-hmm
and then I want to buy Spyro and those
are games I grew up with but they redid
them you made them sick you are done all
right you don't have a [ __ ] old CRT
TV hooked up jab with like a thousand
and one Star Trek wires connecting it to
the [ __ ] thing so you can play the
[ __ ] and you made the kid like plug it
all in so they get the full experience
just like all right now open up your
electrician's manual it's like it's like
that whole thing of like what movie
we were kids we used to be able to blow
up we figured out the blow in the
cartridge door so we didn't have the
online internet [ __ ] and then when
you were a kid your parents are like we
used to go outside yeah exactly
but I'm like dude that wasn't I'm not
romanticizing that [ __ ] that [ __ ] sucked
asked to have to blow on the cartridge
you know but everyone likes to you know
we all our parents had the same
mentality that's like us playing with
pops or some [ __ ] yeah exactly new Magic
marbles yeah that shit's boring my
[ __ ] parents bought me a jar of
marbles I'm like what the [ __ ] am I
supposed to give their trying to teach
me how to play marbles you [ __ ] hit
them and it's like I'd rather have pogs
my grandpa had a Galaga machine whoa
that's cool that's kind of cool as [ __ ]
though it's cool spot [ __ ] cuz he had
the for me show it was like that it's
that one where you're fighting those
aliens and it's like it's like all you
know you've hit in the bunions and they
drop it down on you oh and you hit the
buttons and it fires up huh he had a
Gallagher machine right now I'm just
[ __ ] cool though sorry
it's like Atari yeah I think it is yeah
so yeah so he had that machine it's
sitting in the middle of the [ __ ]
kitchen and he put a tablecloth over it
in a birdcage on top of it and then he
gives us all Jack's for Christmas
why did he do that because he's an
[ __ ]
you got game you'll never play just the
purchase holders you know as a game or
did you you can see the side of it Oh
Peyton it's not yeah I covered it for
ages it just uses a table and then
didn't tell you that it was an actual
game no no no it was a game I said one
that has the ball and like you could
move it and it's like a glass over it
it's like a table there's a glass over
it but that's like an arcade cabinet but
it's like a screen that case is up but
it's sick as far yeah that's cool as
hell yeah but then he gives you jacks
and you're like I could see this thing
yeah
[Music]